we were telling that to myself quite
easy and his 11th season this line in
the recognition to buy balanced units
but Anna no B's hustle failed about them
here's Pascal right to the R as a CEO
that's what I'm talking about
bring it force flowery over to siakam
get on the inside and a great cut by
Kyle by Dallas those deals have come in
the second half
not catching this guy
[Applause]
[Music]
he's got soft hands kids catch and put
it up there quick a scowl quick moves
spinning left hand sweetness great job
on Sarich tip look at this right here
blow by a little spin to his left that
means being on the back lose his head
the line landed with the Pope Leonard
right there here's Pascal Kawhi Leonard
thank you very much
he's over here on the floor
look at her right here he pokes it loose
and at Pascale see outcomes great pass
by this in franchise history
dandy green with a rebound after mcgee
miss a couple of chances here's Ibaka to
pass cap to slab by the way from his
career-high is Serge Ibaka siakam
soaring through the air
ring in the air we're in this the
monster is slapped two seconds to go
[Applause]
Raptors do have a timeout in a row great
recovery by Pascal siakam
they gotta get a score here C octave
Giants on pain spin sit him left-handed
home girl we found tip taken back by
Seattle close with a panic dropped
through here Z a c'mon that I Pascal see
a cam nice screen by JV just giving
enough edge to siak able to get a both
one of the reasons why this is one of
the lower shooting that ball is perfect
row couldn't be any better a limit with
their defense
check out this block by siaka smacks it
off the glass Jackson in Vancouver and
say you know you got make a deal I'm
sure you feel relieved as the guys gonna
get you to bleed nice play
serge ibaka with a slam dunk to start of
the third quarter he'll see us
[Applause]
the shot clock here's Pascal attacking
spinning and a file onto Rodney hood the
beautiful move their time is spent I
appreciate that thank you very much
does that mean that I have to go get you
something here to start the holiday
season up right and get everybody in a
giving spirit finds Ibaka good job by
Serge reeling it in on the tribe here's
a kick it's green quarter thread wrap it
up from porthole Brady has slipped to
Joelle Anthony as you boys yep now will
chirp hosts up siakam sir siaka tutors
to the rebound
Raptors by one quickly here see a
Gophers
[Music]
Joe Harris traveling to turn over here
siakam attacking off the battle greatest
at the Clippers would be not only as a
buckle also is JB and the guards are
playing well Lowry with the steel see it
come to green and Toronto they're here
in Los Angeles rolling mat they're
having fun out there that ball is moving
they're creating opportunities 17-0
fast-break points for the Raptors
he brings it each play just like Victor
Oladipo Kawhi Leonard playing in his
25th game the denial by siakam Pascal
see I kept saying the remains on the
floor he wanted a foul won't get it Kyle
thought about a siakam quick move and
went a lap down
it's a one-point game two points tough
to stop
here's Pascal if album bow Pascal see at
Cahoon on it tonight
look at him right here will think they
will spin he's part of my team tonight
and he'd better get it going since the
10th 15 points down well this game is
different
and it was a little more emotion and I
saw he was fed up at the beginning of
the game maybe taking a couple of plays
he doesn't usually like to remember
there's a big part of the bench misses
and it's either JV or see there Ibaka
depending on which one's siakam soaring
through the air with a two-handed slam
does it go 7 to 13 from the field they
got the look they wanna see honest and
Tennyson scowl going up top continues to
do so many things on the floor help this
team win bridges on them
two seconds to the red buzzer spicy pay
come stroll
look at the time ticking away
and he waited to the last possible
second to take that shot baddie that
basket counts Raptors get the W and how
much confidence does Nick nurse having
this young man to say hey Farrell
driving and it's McCall ahead too
here it is wool comes loose get oh yeah
here we come it coming see a commander
raff is winning virus is really
developed into a nice pro siakam here's
fans fleet and a big time three great
passed by CI come on my guy doesn't hang
his head he misses a open corner three
he comes right back oh yeah coast to
coast he is a witty plan to back Turner
still on him driving at the foul line
cut off great defense best defense in
the NBA and Baghdad and a Pascal siakam
dislike eat ruin update Matty D kills
Hexter only two possessions to the
Raptors fouled siakam for three yes it's
a two-point game with 27 ago I tell you
what the Raptors scrapping
[Applause]
see you coming Scout see if the Raptors
can get something here in transition
siakam to the trailing Gasol Dupree got
the lead for the first time as Marc
Gasol drills it in the Raptors by two
under a minute remaining in the opening
quarter
hochi an Adobe ahead now
Pascal with a slam dunk what did we
mentioned earlier you might be looking
at the most improved player this year in
the NBA and on cue he comes up with the
loose ball the law the siakam piece
kills with the finish steal and the push
Danny Green with the nice lob pass to
siakam you know what Bob Huggins
you know coach at West Virginia VB he
recently came out said the biggest
problem players say I had a beautiful
with the left five Leonard with 11 and I
thought he was strong in the overtime -
which is a good sign
who's shaking his head now Danny gray
[Applause]
sitting there Billy Donovan over to have
a word with the officials mudiay knocks
it down the addition of Gasol siaka
don't celebrate if he's going to get you
good morning hi
look at him he just kind of take it is
time then he turns on the Jets and
nobody protective over to VanFleet with
green sea Ackerman here's Ibaka surge up
fake kicks it out siakam is a great look
by surge throwing it out to see a cup
now if you watch Pascal as we do and
certainly as intently as the fan base
does you know that it's not just based
this play talking about Pascal sack
relief he just has to get that that ball
was waiting for him get the turn the
Jets on big-time client look how soon
that pass is made but you know you make
the point serve a draft version number
two in the leaf basket seconds at number
two score
[Applause]
see a common thread before spicy pee-pee
money make a few more d's
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Dornan loses it here see we picked up
right here you look at nice hands right
there feisty octal finishes on the break
but that when you go to that halftime
you have a few minutes to be able to
make some adjustments here is Kauai pick
to the corner for siakam it beats the
buzzer
driving opportunities on the weak side
good starts for both 48 verge of
exceeded duty where this kid is a bad
bad boy years here it almost have become
kind of an NBA backwater but this place
is electric tonight is 48 turned back by
siakam five to shoot ten seconds left in
the half
here comes Lowry the little hesitation
see I come that's okay
get a commanding trail lead full rockets
cordon just grab the sense that the Jazz
blue huge opportunities last night so
that good fierce finish from Butler in
and out seven don't run for Toronto
Lowry trying to add to it back
[Applause]
Florence water
for assists off the turnover drain
throws it up the siakam
annalee cut 211 beep clear the squeeze
it that's Philadelphia control Simmons
gotta thereby see them now it's a
footrace black rain takes it in and they
block down slow it off he is defensively
here tonight Tennessee ahkam
[Applause]
but the stuff
a skel siaka who has had a tremendous
season mr. good challenge Dennis Davis
Marcia
say items fighters
[Applause]
closest serving your head to the park
better go check it out when he got it
off the salt packs out of three
now Gasol was okay he could have caught
it the 10th only nine field goal
attempts Lowry who sold took the team
Kakashi
29% the three point raid and things are
beginning to heat up
Sayaka with his second field goal
Foster
k'tano this coal is the active on the
following
[Applause]
patience trusting his players or getting
his own man the lead is 1121 for Leonard
I'm a drive dream can't fish job on
curry in Game one despite the fact that
curry got to the free-throw line score
last points McKinney in the game
deflected by Lowry nice pass ahead took
the toll VanFleet to see yeah see a
command he does the rest
outstanding execution defensively
leading the quality offense siakam looks
off of a shot clock ring on the 24
siakam steps back inside the arc and
nails it
Lowry good physical defense nice double
team by the saul and another turnover
Lowry inside Leonard got hit
Gort Leonard shot clock down to three
Leonard gets inside siakam just gets it
off in time and it should he played in
that game the other night well I don't
know any of the medical stuff and I
wasn't obviously that's the option gets
it done what's up you guys this Taylor
Brooks with bleacher report make sure
that you subscribe for some more video
content